Antarctica - the location of the South Pole,
There are also penguins and 5,000 people in the summer.
And less than 1,000 people in the dark winter.
No one lives permanently on this continent,
Who owns Antarctica?
Things outside the borders, such as the seabed, the moon,
The entire space is often regarded as the "common heritage of mankind."
It does not belong to anyone, but at the same time belongs to all, and is kept by us for transmission to the next generation.
This is good, but the whole universe is ours.
It may be a bit overdone,
In the end, others may have a little opinion.
But this is another story.
Human beings, doing well.
However, things are never so simple.
Because the document on the Antarctic is roughly called Antarctica as a common heritage of mankind,
But there is no more in-depth explanation.
The reason is the explorer in the 19th century
Started to land in Antarctica and set the flag.
And declare the right to occupy. However, these statements are a bit vague.
Because in the civilized science tree, Antarctica
Can't be colonized. However, like the Monopoly game,
The best colonial strategy is to occupy all the places where you landed.
In the early 20th century, the British tried to declare the occupation of the entire Antarctic.
Then she reduced her ambitions.
Instead, only declare that the occupation of the coastal part that has been surveyed by the United Kingdom.
France also stated that the occupied part of the occupied coastal part,
The same approach was followed by Norway, as well as those of the Nazis.
Later, the declarations of Argentina and Chile occupied the overlap of the region with the United Kingdom.
At that time, the powers had no time to manage this matter.
But after the UK
And her independent colonies finally began to deal with this matter.
This led to a mess of declared occupations on Antarctica.
Especially in a dangerous era where there should be no major territorial disputes.
The United States and the Soviet Union respectively
Grant yourself a declaration of occupation on Antarctica
The right, but neither party will make a statement immediately, but delay the decision.
Under this premise, in 1959, the United States, the Soviet Union, and
The other ten countries are Argentina, Australia, Belgium,
Chile, France, Japan, New Zealand, Norway,
South Africa and the United Kingdom have unusually succeeded in creating a treaty to ease tensions among nations.
Marked on the treaty in Antarctica
Military activities, mining and nuclear tests are not allowed.
This Antarctic document is the first in the Cold War.
Disarmament treaty for science and nature
And the conservation of Antarctica.
By the way, because Antarctica is a nature conservation area,
There is a rule about garbage - "Never leave anything behind,"
It is "anything." If you arrive in Antarctica in the summer,
You will be leaving with your own stool in the winter.
So this treaty looks very good, but "common heritage"
What is wrong with this line?
Well, no one actually gave up their declared occupied area on Antarctica.
Because the only way for everyone to sign a treaty is
Added this article to avoid the problem.
Countries that basically sign the treaty will "like"
Antarctica is treated as a "common heritage of mankind" without the right to occupy,
But there is no country in law.
Abandoned the occupation, so the map of Antarctica
It usually includes the areas that are claimed to be occupied.
This blank area is completely unoccupied.
Make it the largest unmanned area on the planet,
At least until now.
Now no longer like the colonial era of the past, all countries have technology,
Allow them to build a permanent base on duty in Antarctica.
It’s just that countries happen to build their bases in
There is no clear answer to the territorial disputes in the occupied territories.
According to the treaty, Antarctica belongs to everyone,
But the treaty itself has a deliberate loophole.
So Antarctica exists in this area of ​​true and false occupation.
Strange state. Some countries are in their own "occupied areas"
Construction bases, and some countries that do not have an "occupied area" in Antarctica,
For example, China has also built her base in Antarctica.
Because Antarctica belongs to everyone, right? Everyone?
These occupied areas are meaningless until
The mining ban was re-examined in 2040.
Oh, it’s very likely that there is a lot of oil under Antarctica.
Not to mention that 70% of the world's fresh water reserves,
Fresh water may become a very precious resource in the future.
The United States and the Soviet Union...oh...Russia may use them
The right to occupy the custody. However, until now,
Antarctica still maintains the state stated in the treaty, is a
A continent-level shelter for nature conservation and research. (IvanKT rough translation)
Squarespace is for you and your mind
The easiest way to create a beautiful web page, blog and online store.
I am really happy to have them become my sponsors.
Because I personally use Squarespace to run cgpgrey.com
And hellointernet.com, this is a podcast I made with Brady.
If you are going to make a website, no matter what it is,
I personally recommend Squarespace to you.
And if you press this link or use the promotion number "Grey",
You will get a 10% discount on checkout. So if you have
Consider creating a website of your own, press this link,
Go to Squarespace and give them a chance.
This can help Squarespace, as well as this channel.
Squarespace, beautifully created.